let me say something that you might not
like I think all four of you know that
God really exists I think you do know
you don't want it to be true that's
putting I said you might not like it
right we are approaching the 150th
episode of middle ground and we need
your help to continue making more
episodes join our middleground patreon
community and make middle ground with
us Christianity is the only true
religion can the agers please step
forward it's kind of interesting because
there are so many religions but and I
don't even consider myself religious I
consider myself a child of God I have a
relationship with Jesus so I would say
the only true way to heaven the only
true way to Eternal everlasting life is
Christianity well I'm surprised that all
of us came forward because uh well I'm a
pastor so that's expected of me but I've
noticed that it's such a hard thing to
say today rather than it was like 30
years ago because you so many people get
offended I mean you didn't say anything
else except Jesus is the only way and
right there people don't want to talk to
you right it's really true true for me I
think um all religions teach you to do
well um but Christianity is the only
religion that teaches you you can't do
it without God you can't do it without
Jesus so for me I couldn't get out of my
depression I couldn't get out of my
loneliness I could only maintain um I
needed something to save me pull me out
of that and so you know I grew a
Buddhist but uh with Christianity I was
able to really step out of that frame of
thinking of I'm My Own God I have to
take care of my own issues and God was
the one that helped me in everything
praise be to God Amen I mean I really
don't want to seem like my religion is
better than yours kind of deal it's
simply what Jesus claimed for himself
yeah so you know can the disag reers
please
join
if we like reflect on the aspect of the
only true religion or the only true
religion for me it it it's it's a
sleeper slope because if you substitute
religion with nationalism we can all of
the sudden see the problems with it you
know I get it I think that religion
organized religion can cause a lot of
ISS the message of Jesus Christ the
embodiment of love right but yeah I
truly believe in my heart I do not think
people that do not know him are just
going to burn in the fiery pits I don't
think it's that black and white but yes
I truly do believe it's he Jesus Christ
is Christianity is the only way my
Epiphany was like walking down Route 101
in in Pennsylvania and thinking oh my
God this idea behind Christianity is
that everyone that doesn't just Ascent
believe in this one thing they're going
to burn forever mhm and that was like my
Epiphany like oh man I I you know it is
fun not fun it is
fulfilling to have a very black and
white way of looking at the world right
that I remember how great that felt but
also like my Epiphany is oh there has to
be more in the world in the universe
than that that can't be the end of it
like that I mean that might be like an
all- knowing god but that's not an all
loving God you know it can't be all you
know yeah I was going to say I'm so
jealous
that you guys feel like it's the only
religion like I felt I wish I felt that
way still but um I just don't know
anything and there's millions of
religions how can you say
100% that it's the only true one you
can't but I know in your hearts you can
and I wish I had that so bad but I I
just don't it's like this in answer to
your question I mean I haven't studied
every religion to say this is wrong this
is right but I do know that Jesus is
real based on what he's done in my life
and I know the Bible is real based on
archaeology and prophecy and Jesus says
he's the only way so I I'll believe him
I mean he could be lying I could be
wrong what if I said that toes special
Jesus proved himself to me by saving me
by doing miracles in my life what if I
yeah but that's anotal you haven't saved
me what if I do though what if he does
what if anybody else you should I
believe that you experience that and and
that it's powerful and if if that makes
you a better human being
fantastic the issue is that it's
anecdotal to go to your to to what you
were saying how can you prove without
just the basis of faith that this is the
absolute truth Christian apologetics
like right but the Christian apologetics
disagree in a bunch of of different
aspects you know and unique no they
don't actually well they they do you
know and you really need to focus on
whether you are going to theologically
accept the Bible as the absolute
document of Truth what are you gonna
Sherry pick from it what are you gonna
accept as oh this was just a historical
thing you're saying when J said you know
you can't change an Iota here it's hard
because like I feel like I'm hyper
liberal too and stuff because I'm like
you know what I mean and stuff but then
I know right but then it's like it's
kind of true to a degree like sometimes
I I don't honestly feel like I cherry
pick from the Bible like I'm like well
they still eat shellfish so I can be
with them
you know what I mean it's so tough
because it's like I only know how to
love a man as much as I would love to be
what normal is this is just who I Who I
Am normal I want to know why selfish
keep coming up in these debates it's a
weird entry in the Bible That's why very
very bizarre well there's things that we
were meant to abstain from and then
there was a time when God said
everything is clean so I mean that's the
thing is like if you're act if you're
actually studying as far as food if
you're actually studying the Bible and
if if you're actually looking into the
history the science the theology about
that that's where you're going to get
your questions answered but if you don't
I am still ignorant of of the Bible like
I'm not it's only been like maybe seven
years for me and stuff and uh I admit I
could probably learn so much from you
and stuff just from hearing how you
speak about it seems like you're very
knowledgeable and stuff so I have 28
years of the Bible and I still don't
fuing understand it it's very
contradictory there's other books you
guys it's okay the Bible is always is
open to
interpretation
sorry the Bible is so confusing every
Christian Cherry picks everybody does
you're not supposed to lie you lie yeah
so how can you not interpret it in so
many ways and it's been obviously
transcribed so many times you know
adding the word homosexual and all this
and it's just the doctrine of hell not
very clear 100% it's all just a if you
look at the god that's portrayed in the
Old Testament and the New Testament both
it looks a lot more like us than it
looks like an all knowing all good kind
of situation you're like oh yeah this
totally came to uh get people to
cooperate with the power you know
jealousy Vengeance these are human
qualities my my argument or my issue
with uh interpreting is that you know we
as human beings that's what we do you
know we have something and we have to
interpret it my issue is it all boils
down and distilled to is it Divine or is
it not and am I allowed to pick things
out or am I not you know there are so
many issues with the with the claim of
divinity because it's not that it's open
to interpretation it's that it's always
being interpreted there are conclaves
you know so languages yeah you know that
are built just to do that you know to to
decide which book goes in which book
comes out you know yeah Martin Luther
took out like 10 books or something and
they're like why'd you do that and he's
like that's not what God wanted it's
like okay Martin Luther yeah one of the
biggest reasons why I steep forward is
again because I think it's a guideline
not an absolute it was tough for me
because I'm very much like you know I
believe in Jesus Christ and whatever God
says he wants and it's tough to even
realistically do that every day like
every day I sin because I kiss this man
that I love and like then I jump on a
box and go to only fans. you know what I
mean like it's it's tough feeling like
everything that you do that's just a
everyday thing and it has zero to do
with how you treat people at the end of
the day the rainbow that it gets to and
stuff and pot of gold is that Jesus
Christ is all loving he loves everybody
he hung out with someone who was like me
like a hey don't
s and was still was like Hey you you're
still can be this good person don't let
the world tell you this and but I
believe that in some way the Bible is
telling you that is telling you like
this is hey it's okay to not be this I
think it's maybe organized religion that
gets it muffled and there's all this
hate towards everyone cuz I'm like I'm
sorry I don't think that Jesus Christ
hated trying to organize all of the
Bible and make it make sense that's
going to fail not very clear whether
it's telling us to do good things or do
bad things it has kind of a combination
of both in
there thank you I'm actually glad that
you brought up the whole translations
thing because that is something that I
used to question as well and once I
looked into it every modern translation
of the Bible is actually translated from
Greek Hebrew or Aramaic which are
ancient languages so it's not that we're
just continuing to translate from
whatever was Modern to another modern
like no and that's why if you've ever
heard of the Dead Sea Scrolls it's
ancient text from the Bible where if you
were to compare it to the Bible today
only things different is like
punctuation well that's amazing because
that was one of the most amazing
discoveries of this Century in that they
discovered the Dead Sea Scrolls and they
thought they would correct all these
mistakes in the Bible but it was so
amazing that
99.999% was accurate so they were
amazed second Peter 1:20 tells us that
no scriptures for interpretation so it's
actually for us to accept rather than
understand and for me personally like
when I try to understand so I have a kid
when he was 5 years old I tried to
explain to him like mortgage I had money
in my pocket I was still poor I was
living in the projects right my kid was
like let me get bubble gum and I was
like I can't I don't have enough money I
don't want to like buy him the clothes I
couldn't buy him the clothes but in his
mind he was understanding it as dad you
don't love me right and I'm like but I
do love you as much as I explained it to
him he couldn't understand it he was
very miserable because of that Bible
tells us at least for me that we're all
children in God like we we're not we're
finite beings we cannot understand
infinite things so when I when I learned
to stop trying to understand rather and
just accept then I was able to truly be
free for me personally that's like
growing up it was like I would ask my
parents CU my parents are super
religious trumpers borderline Q andon
scary
2024 come and um I was terrified of the
Rapture anytime I said anything about
the Rapture it's always just like well
you're thinking with your human brain
you're not thinking with your heavenly
brain I'm like but I only have a human
brain like I can only understand what I
can understand here can I ask you
something too I wanted to know like so
do you believe like say if someone's
kind and treats people right and it's a
really good-hearted soul but say they
really don't believe in anything perhaps
God right do you believe that they're
going to burn just because they don't
believe I think that God invites us all
to have a life with him in eternity and
I think a lot of times we're like he's
just want to throw people in hell but
he's like if you want to be with me in
eternity these are the qualifications
Jesus is the only that's but terms and
yeah you think they'll burn in say yes
the good person will burn in hell if
they don't know Jesus yes they will not
be with God for eternity so that makes
me not want to know that guy I think
step back a little bit because we've
been dancing around it a little bit but
I relating to the prompt though I I
would like to know how you became exch
Christians I think that might help us
yeah that would be really nice by
reading the Bible okay I think
do you mind if I ask if you have a
religion I do not have any organized
religion I don't really believe in
anything Supernatural I I am technically
part of the satanic temple uh we only
have seven rules we don't have an entire
book we don't need to is that considered
a religion I'm just curious it is
technically considered an religion a
religion but it's like the religion to
end all religions they really hate
organized religion they kind of want to
just have everybody um focus on Humanity
putting differences aside treating each
other with respect I guess what I'm
asking is uh so there was a time when
you called yourself a Christian how did
you become an ex-christian what made
that change so it all started when my
family uh I was 22 years old I I started
asking like specifically like if you
want an example of something the Bible
says in Exodus 20 these are the Ten
Commandments and then it lists things
that God only verbally spoke but then
later if you go to Exodus 34 it mentions
The Ten Commandments and they're a
little bit different I would encourage
you to go look at Exodus 34 especially
uh the 10th commandment do not boil a
goat in your mother's in its mother's
milk that's a fun one we should be
adhering to that today right well if
Jesus never came and created a New
Covenant then yeah there's a lot of
things we'd still be doing sure those
are part of the 613 laws which is called
the Mitzvah and um people don't know
that we're not under those laws anymore
we're also not under pretty much any law
because it says Romans 6:14 we're free
right we're free from from from the law
I mean that's just one example if you
really want to focus on the things that
most Christians say should be relevant
that would be the gospels right you guys
would agree with that absolutely right
so let's look at all four gospels let's
compare them to one another and tell me
that there are not contradictions in
them that one event happened and also
the simultaneous other event happened
like was Judas did he die in the desert
or did somebody kill him like it never
says anybody killed him it says he hung
himself yeah he hung himself he fell
head long right and then yeah or was he
killed by the the people that he was
paid off by we could have a NPI
theological discussion
with could but I also want to know so
your other your experience is that
similar difficulty with the Bible so you
kind of walked away so my I talked about
my Epiphany experience but also when I
came out to my mom you know I went to uh
you know Christian Camp and Bible
College when I came out to my mom she
ripped up my birth certificate and sent
it to me my which is very like you know
I said to my therapist I was like oh
that
that was so passive aggressive my
therapist like no no that was
aggressive no passive but um you know we
came to find each other I was the only
of her five kids that was holding her
hand when she died you know um you know
we prayed together but that that
experience was one of the ones where I
was like it's not just about me I
actually I lost two partners in a row to
cancer which is just you know kind of
horrible yeah but I know that there is
something that I have faith in and it's
not Christianity and it's not God but
that I was the right people to sit with
both those women as they died right and
that is like what I have faith in I wish
that I still had Christianity I wish
that that was something that I could
still stomach because like I mean except
for you saying you like Trump like I
think we would have a lot of fun right
like I actually I already like Trump
doesn't have to come I love Trump you
don't got to be there so you know I
still have that faith I just wish it
could come in a Christian package but
that just does not work for me I feel
like the world is too big for that you
know and and I see your reaction when
she mentioned the birth certificate most
of the good uh Christian friends that I
have react the same way as you do and
the problem is that's the norm her
experience in Christian households is
the norm that's crazy it's the norm I I
came out to my family I am a happily
married man for 15 years and I my family
hates me because of that you know there
there's a a an issue with that so that
becomes the norm and when when that's
the norm you need to really question
yeah you know what's happening in there
so I feel like a lot of people think
that Christians are allowed to judge and
if they don't read the Bible they don't
understand that we're not allowed to
judge um so that's why a lot of this
sounds like like kind of your personal
problems with your families who claim to
be Christian and this is no disrespect
but if you really are Christian you're
not called to judge anybody we're all
interconnected by sin if I stand in
front of God as a ex gang member and you
stand in front of God as a homosexuality
we're both on the same level so we have
to recognize that so I do agree with
with people when they say you know the
community here when they're saying that
you know Christianity and people try to
act as holier than thou that's not what
true Christianity 100% I'm just hearing
you said my mom wasn't a good Christian
now I'm mad at you for that yeah like I
my mom was a good Christian she was
doing what her I mean maybe a little
dramatic right it seems a little gay to
rap up you know some oh my God you know
but my mom was a good Christian like she
was doing what she thought she needed to
do to keep me from going to hell like
she no joke that's what she thought was
the most loving thing in that
moment if I may add if I may add to that
that what you what you said is correct
you know if you want to be a rightful uh
you know correct Christian you're not
called to judge the problem is going
back to what I mentioned it's the norm
so we need to ask ourselves what is
happening with the majority of
Christians uh families or households
that are all reacting like could just go
talk to your people please that would be
great believe me I do yeah I know you do
hey I know this discussion can feel like
a lot thankfully our partner for this
video the Skylight app has simple no
fuss spiritual exercises that can work
for anybody religious or not here let me
take you through some affirmations I
learned things are neither good nor bad
they just are I can feel the stress
flowing out of me as I slow down and
focus on my breath I can get through
anything with the help of my higher
power with each breath I let go of my
stress I will overcome this stressful
situation as I turn toward that higher
power whatever that higher power may be
my anxiety turns to patience the
Skylight app has tons more exercises
like this and it's all totally free
check them out at skylight. org thanks
so much to Skylight for sponsoring this
portion of the episode now let's get
back to it you can be gay and Christian
I feel that you need to
start please well this huh
obviously in stuff I'm a big old uh
fruit cake I bartend in night life I go-
go dance I do adult content I love it I
love having sex with wom which almost
sounds bad now that I'm saying out loud
it's amazing but I uh I still love the
Bible I treat people with respect I uh
go to confession I do all these things I
love my lgbtqia community and I'm a gay
man a big o fruit and I love it so going
to say one of the reasons I became an
ex-christian was because I met gay
people because I grew up in a Christian
small conservative town and my parents
like pushed it into me they're like what
are the two things we vote on as
Christians and I'd have to say abortion
and gay marriage like brainwash so I met
gay people and I was like why did my
parents say you're bad you know and it's
like it's just crazy just living life is
how I became an ex-christian and just I
hate the fact that like my mom says you
can be gay you just can't act on it and
I'm like so you want someone to go their
whole life without loving someone and
people kill themselves because of that
for me I just think it's kind of pervy
that there is this thought that he is so
involved in what you do in bed
Christians are involved in people's beds
well the reason I'm sitting here I think
I also probably before the other two
join us I think I'm probably in line
with them too I'm just answering the
prompt in that can a gay person believe
that Jesus Christ died on the cross for
his sins and that he is risen again that
Jesus is God yes yes definitely and can
go to heaven and I and I'm a Christian
and I think most of us don't care about
what people do in their bedrooms but we
do care about other people saying no no
your God says this is okay when the
Bible strictly says it's homosexuality
is sin how does that make you feel when
he says that when they say again
interpreting right so they have it
interpreted saying that they meant
mainly when it was older men having sex
with young men because there wasn't a
word to translate for uh just something
else like men
and yeah so I don't believe he
necessarily meant being in love with a
man or a woman with a woman and sub so I
believe is for men with younger men who
didn't couldn't determined didn't have a
choice I've heard that before and I
speak Greek and I read and write Greek
and if you look at that passage in
Romans chapter 1 it's not about the word
it actually describes men having sexual
acts with other men I'm going to burn in
the fiery no but God forgives yeah
he does he does I believe you have a
real faith in Jesus of your sin I love
Jesus Christ and I know that the Bible's
not going to change for me too like I
know that if this is truly a sin then I
have to answer to that when I go it's
not there's nothing I can do also
there's nothing I want to do though I
love who I love and I truly believe
Jesus Christ the embodiment of love is
like I get it I feel like he's always
kind of like letting me know like I'm
glad you're you're you're on the right
path all I agree with you I think that's
you know if you're going to practice
something at least practice a good part
of
it I love to hear this I believe the
Bible I believe what it says and I also
understand in the Bible that it says
that the unrighteous will not inherit
the kingdom of God or take or have any
part of it and it lists a lot of
different sins and I think that there's
a difference between people falling
short we all do we all make mistakes we
all struggle we're all figuring out our
identity all of that yeah but when it
for me the difference is if you are
purposely day in and day out saying this
is what I want to do and this is how I
want to live my life and it goes
completely against the word of God
that's when I feel you have you have
separated yourself from the Lord and you
will not enter into the Kingdom of
Heaven do you have gay friends I do not
have gay friends I barely have friends
period but I can't see that I actually
SE think that you would be around a lot
of people cuz you're so bubble gummy and
warm friend I know be gay friend there
was a time though the reason why that
happened I'm not trying to get being on
Mory or something but like I've had
friends but what I noticed is I was
attracted to a lot of toxic friendships
that were very one-sided so what I had
to do is like get rid of that and God
actually called me to be closer to him I
entered into Ministry I do YouTube stuff
but anyways so now is the time I have a
church Community I have friends but it's
I for me a friend is someone who also
draws me closer to Christ do you think
that I truly will go to even though I'm
Catholic and I practice just because I
love a man cuz I can't like I can't I'll
be miserable like I've tried being alone
and it's hard you know I want someone
that's there that I I want to love and I
want to take care of them and I want to
provide for him and do all that and all
I want to do is have someone like
everyone else and I don't think that
Jesus Christ wants me not to but I don't
think loving anybody is wrong but we're
talking love and sexuality are two
different categories and I know that the
Lord believes in Christian marriage man
and woman who are monogamous and who are
not going to be cheating on each other
fornicating all that stuff so with you
honestly I'm just going to go a little
off script I know you're
searching I know you are I and I know
you mean it and I know that there's
things that you feel like you can't
change yeah and know that you have a
genuine
sorry I know I know what you're saying
cuz I can see in you you you remind me
of my grandma and I say this in this way
because she's hyper Christian and she
feels like if she starts approving or
liking something like this it's tough
because you're like if I like if I love
someone who does this it goes against my
faith but all you want to do though
you're like this person's cool I get
along with them they're not going to
they're we're going to the same place
right do you feel that you're searching
I don't think that I'm searching what
would you to say to him when he says I'm
not searching I feel that I found well
the thing I was going to go forward and
say is I do believe that you want to
please the Lord and I know that you're
thank you so he's that enough I know
that you feel like you can't change and
there's a lot of people like that heavy
breaths heavy size oh my gosh she said
that I know that you feel that you can't
change can we get to the root of why
homosexuality is wrong
so and it goes against God's designed
for
family so here's the here's the thing
right guys um I think we're focusing too
much on this thing that's like so for me
sin is more of like a virus right
there's symptoms of this virus right gay
virus right so no it's not a gay virus
what I'm saying is I'm trying to make a
differentiation between sin and what we
think is actual sin right so if if it
enters our body and we have a fever
let's say runn nose fever sore throat if
I take Tylenol and I take aspirin my
fever will suppress right but if I don't
attack the virus at its core then it'll
keep still popping up do you guys
understand what I'm saying with the with
does analogy relate to what's wrong he's
getting to the point so I'm getting to
the point true sin like a like I said is
it's a virus it stems from unbelief it
stems from trusting and believing in
myself right so I knew for example that
you can't just kill people but I was
like you know what I'm going to be a
gang member my dad beat me he was an
alcoholic my mom all of that was an
excuse right I chose like she was saying
right so I chose I'm going to follow my
thoughts and believe in myself do you
guys understand and from that I became a
gang member when I lived my own way and
I trusted my own self essentially being
my own God when you trusted yourself yes
another decision I'm I'm I'm I'm really
sorry I'm really really sorry everything
that you're bringing up to the table are
decisions when did you chose to be gay
right no I did not there was no choice
for me you can't help who you fall in
love with right and like say if you are
are you biracial if you don't mind me
asking yeah so ditto and stuff and uh
you know like uh at some point maybe our
parents and stuff right people are like
how dare you be with this you know our
grandparents you know what I mean and so
but it's like you can't help who you
love and you're not supposed to but
people told them they were supposed to
so I can't help who I fall in love with
and I'm not supposed to because Jesus
Christ he did all these things with
people that were very not uh they're all
supposed to go to hell Jus didn't follow
the Bible not very he was he was extr
follow he was extremely kind and loving
to everybody and said no matter what and
stuff just just trust in my heart do you
understand that he also is saving people
healing them and also saying go and send
no more he wasn't saying let's all party
and let people like to say he's L
someone though isn't isn't partying and
having a good time being like at the bar
that's having like companionship and
love compion saying even the woman who
was caught in adultery he wasn't saying
don't throw a stone at her you're okay
keep doing that he was like stop that
don't do that anymore he was saying
don't be a harlot or don't be extra
about it right and stuff but me there is
nothing he made me this way there is
I can do how many testimonies have you
seen G in the LGBT we can agree to
disagree how many you can't disagree
though about my life though we can argu
we can argue
the
can hypothetically I'm not that I was
born this way you say what do you say
about all of the people who have come
out of the LGBT lifestyle and have said
this is where it started I can pinpoint
something happened I can pinpoint a
trauma I can pinpoint they weren't just
their
story let's accept it let's accept it as
true let's just give that as true what
makes the other thing false right 100%
like I don't understand have you can go
through trauma and whoa yeah that made
you whoever you are that's not my
story that's and I'm still who I'm still
glad your life was really great well I
don't think we could just focus just on
homosexuality for two hours well that
was the prompt but uh I don't know Jake
I don't know his experience and I can't
judge his heart but if Jake really
believed Jesus Christ as his Lord and
Savior dying on the cross for his sins
yes I think God will work in his heart I
mean there are sins in my life that I
haven't repented of I'm not perfect
either I think I think in heaven no one
is gay yes gay people can become
Christians and go to heaven but in
heaven
what I'm so sick of Christians comparing
like they say all sin is equal they
don't believe that like lifestyle it's a
day-to-day thing if I'm always lying I'm
always cheating I'm I have no I have
those things are bad those are decision
why is being gay bad and again those are
decision to murder question violence I
stud theology for many for you is it
purely just cuz it's in the Bible like
not when you see me like if you saw me
kiss a a guy or like hold hands you
don't come off this way as someone who
seems like that's offputting to you it's
not because of that it's because well
theologically I don't know why the Bible
is against it I don't know why God says
these things then ask those questions
the Bible is clear in saying this is
God's standard and I don't I I don't
understand the whole Mind Of God well
why don't you understand about there's a
design for family you could say it's
about the natural order of creation that
you know of procreation and and how God
made things the way they are end now
that's my interpretation I can't say
100% that that's what I want not even
nature that doesn't even Happ in nature
I can't think for God but I do know what
the Bible is clear in its teachings
don't question would you be what's on
your mind um no I mean I I do really
feel for you because I do understand
that that this it sounds condescending
to say but I understand you believe that
the Bible says is being gay is wrong
like I get like and that is how I always
felt growing up and what I watched is as
like clearly gay people of my generation
I watch them kill themselves I watch try
I've watch them try to be different I
watch them live lives of just complete
desperation I watch them have get
married to women and have sex on the
side like I watch them I watch these
beautiful people these beautiful like
loving people made of love and who had
so much to give the world try to subvert
a an important part of themselves to fit
into this idea like this one or two
lines from the Bible and as I said that
as I said when you mentioned uh
testimony and I said that was anecdotal
I will also come back and say that's
also anecdotal but we can go then back
to the legislation if you have a
fundamentalist person that believes that
that's wrong and they manage to get into
the legislature they will pass a bill
against it so we're not e we're not
uh in a in a plane field for equality
for all so the fact that you have even
if you don't understand where it comes
from the fact that you have that belief
and you will force yourself into
government to then decide for other
people I don't understand it's just it's
a big no you know cuz I truly do feel
God enjoys love I prayed and prayed and
prayed to find love and stuff and I was
like I'm so lonely and it's like I'm
getting to that place where I might have
that with someone and I feel so happy
and this guy goes he's Catholic he goes
to church and he goes to confession and
he loves these things and it makes me
feel so good do you feel like part of
that relation relationship was filling a
hole and a void that maybe Jesus could
have filled maybe if you focus on that
first question CU I've been focusing on
it for about I've been single for about
like seven years your Jesus hole is
filled already with Jesus itself right
Jesus is inside the
hole excuse me
Lord oh my god oh
man in the past I've experienced
unexplainable Supernatural
events come on let's go let's go
I've questioned if what I believe is
true that's the nature of knowledge is
all about that's the nature of knowledge
reality look at that a middle ground
look at that I even question like being
an ex-christian sometimes I call myself
a hopeful agnostic I sure as H
something's out there because that's
really depressing if there's not but if
there isn't that's cool too I just yeah
like obviously we all became
ex-christians because we started
questioning what we believe and I think
that's really important to like solidify
your faith as well like on your side too
yeah thank you for saying that because
that is true like that is something me
questioning is something that has
solidified my faith a lot more finding
information about like the evidence of
Christ the evidence of God cuz I feel
like honestly you'd be lying to yourself
if you didn't say that it took Faith to
believe in anything it takes Faith to
believe in the Big Bang it takes Faith
to believe that there's this void out
here there why would you say that
because you don't know Were You There
When The Big Bang happened we don't need
to be there we have likelihood were you
there we don't need to be there we can
measure that light from the from the
science keep changing it changes like
every year after we discovered we were
wrong because of the same way neonian
physics Chang into Einstein the same way
things evolve knowledge keeps on growing
the the the huis of Christianity to say
we have everything figured out and
everything is true science has
humbleness to say we know only this and
we keep on researching to to grow our
knowledge science doesn't claim to know
everything your belief system does claim
to know everything and doesn't move off
of that point science keeps updating
making itself more and more accurate
that's the the beauty of life that's the
beauty of living is to keep learning and
I think that's crazy so to keep saying
that every time something changes
that we thought to be true this is
awesome we were wrong we we thought that
we didn't need to wash our hands before
surgery yeah and then all of the sudden
I'm glad that we discovered that then
all of the sudden we we discovered the
microbes and how that affected you know
the health of of the body and then all
of a sudden stop saying you know then
just be like we we never said we knew we
said we were humble in science to know
that we know what we know and we're
constantly trying to grow that knowledge
we don't have the hubris to say we know
everything I think it's so important to
be like know everything either I can't
prove that God exists but I also can't
prove that he doesn't exist I love that
you said that and I appreciate that like
and I hope you all say that too like you
can't 100% prove God I agree that's what
faith is speaking about belief um I've
spoken to a lot of ex-christians because
uh six years ago I started a Ministry
called Uber evangelism trained about a
do yeah dozen people to go across the
country to drive for Uber and also talk
about Jesus spoken to a lot of people
got saved the Uber drivers talk to you
about it I'm the Uber driver who talks
about Jesus you think that's harassment
aside from going over that um so I've
spoken to a lot of people from different
perspectives different religions and it
really enhanced my faith in Christ but
also I've also spoken to a lot of
ex-christians and you could tell me if
I'm wrong but although the stats say
it's because of they disagree with some
of the church's political stand negative
experience but from my conversations
with them it appeared that most of them
became ex-christians because they just
don't believe in Jesus is that right I
for me I'm a extremely reluctant
ex-christian right like I would like to
be a Christian but I it it things don't
seem true like what you mean by not
believing in Jesus like that he's the
son of God of course everybody knows he
he's existed I mean that's that's under
debate right but but that he's the son
of God not that he existed okay but yeah
believe that he is the Son of God died
for people's sins I like his messaging I
like the things that he said a lot of
people do I think a lot of people really
like those and like thank you for
clarifying I'm talking about believing
in Jesus as Lord and savior is what I'm
talking about yeah or well maybe not
just in the way that you say right like
like I could believe in Jesus but not
definitely not that thing so that's why
Christianity doesn't work for me anymore
right for me in my case it's just that
through study uh and
a a truly unbiased research and honest
searching I arrived at the conclusion
that Christianity as it is presented to
us so far throughout the ages I believe
it deeply immoral and the image of God
it's deeply immoral and the and some of
the teachings that are there are
incredibly immoral so I I don't
subscribe to that because I do believe
that I do have a better moral Compass I
find it hard to believe that you came to
that conclusion based on objective
research
yeah colonialism Manifest Destiny
slavery what is not denied or or
rejected in the Bible so there are a
whole bunch of immoral things that
happen in the Bible that some apologist
will say well no no no no that was a
historical thing that everyone did so it
has to be documented as the thing that
happened historically so is it human or
is it Divine so so you know I just I
just it for me it's just Immortal going
back to the original prompt I think um
for me it doesn't matter how much I tell
my testimony I always question whether
or not people are going to accept God
through it if you guys don't accept then
that's okay you know it's for me it's
kind of like a all you can eat buffet
you know it's like you could pick and
choose you want the chow or the sushi
you know what I'm saying like there's
still only one to answer I mean
technically it's fine that you believe
that there is one right answer if it's
for you and your truth that's fine you
know that's that's a very postmodernism
approach you know I think from my
perspective that that's right as long as
you don't intervene with my perspective
we're cool for sure well I get what
you're saying because uh there's a lot
of crap in institutional religion
including Christianity judging hypocrisy
uh abuse so I get it when people walk
away from the church but don't walk away
from Jesus 100% I'll tell you a like a
thing I just can't grasp is like okay
we're born we didn't ask to be here M we
are flawed from the
beginning life from a Biblical Jesus
standpoint seems like it's one big test
that we have to pass and if we don't I'm
a good person I think I would go to
heaven but I won't because I can't force
myself to believe in Jesus and God
that's what I don't believe and I know
that you do believe I don't think that
Jesus Christ the embodiment of Love is
saying going to hell cuz you were kind
to me that's what the Bible says for
being kind you're going to hell for not
surrendering to Jesus
Christ
Nally that's not her fault game the game
is like we're throwing you here and you
decide so Hitler's on his deathbed and
he says God I Believe In You Hitler is
going to heaven and I'm not what the is
that about on his death bed yes he would
go to heaven yeah I do believe we have
free will and when we come to these
things like oh this was wrong and we
learn from him I think that is what his
version of believing in me is she
believed in love and kindness which is
Jesus Christ so that's what I believe
would send her and everyone else to
heaven so I'm going to challenge that
then why don't cut the middleman and
just believe in kindness I wish I could
it's not about that the Bible's purpose
that God's purpose wasn't about trying
to make people good or to improve people
or to fill people with love the purpose
was to save
people everybody needs Jesus let me say
something that you might not like I
think all four of you know that God
really exists deep down I think you do
know any however you don't want it to be
true and so
whatever right I said you might not like
it right not like it and categorically
accepting it but let me finish my
thought though no that because you don't
want it to be true okay maybe not
specific to you but for the people in
the scientific Community or historical
Community they don't want the god to be
true that's telling them what's right
and wrong that what they're doing is
wrong a generalization right this is a
generalization so I'm saying probably
most likely the scientific community and
others who are skeptical because they
don't want it to be true you're
presenting margin of error probably
maybe this thing that other thing that's
a margin of er it's not a brain thing
it's a heart condition that's not even
worse
exactly I fear
death
yeah I'd be
lying
yay I wish I didn't fear death but I do
yeah like and I used to be since I grew
up in like a private school my whole
life fire and brimstone baby like you
are going to burn burn burn and I've
done my research and I don't think that
hell is a literal place but sometimes
I'm like but what if like the pastors in
the back of my mind that I've gone
through in youth group I'm like but what
if it is but I refuse to live like
fear-based and just believe in God
because I'm scared like that's not
living to me and I can't like force
myself to believe in it I know my
opinion doesn't matter but I I'm sorry I
just don't believe that you're going to
hell I love there's just a there's just
a aura about people that are just bad
and evil and want they're they're going
you know what I mean there's no there's
no way in
you're going there so but I I feel uh I
fear what death will feel like I'm like
man I I feel like it's going to hurt and
I'm I hate saying that because I'm such
a pansy but I am terrified of pain and
and stuff unless it's the good kind you
know warron you know a little
little but it it uh that terrifies me
also because I am afraid of what's going
to happen to the people that actually
care about me just knowing that they're
going through something and I can't be
there to comfort them well apparently
you're not even going to know what's
happening down there that's what
Christians have told me like I won't
even think about them you won't even
know them when they come up to heaven I
don't believe that like they say that
you won't recognize your like partner
wow when you're yeah um I thought Heaven
Was supposed to be heaven and uh my
heaven includes them you know I always
just thought like do I want to live
forever sounds so exhausting so I hope
when I die it's just like in the ground
and just like resting I hope not I want
us to hang out up there I want us to go
to a club up there yeah we Kiki up
there going
on I used to be super afraid of dying um
and then you know had two partners in a
row die and uh when people talk about an
afterlife I'm like really another life
after this one that's sounds like a lot
yeah can only if I can only watch like
HBO documentaries or something you know
um are you okay you okay you all
right
okay can I give you a hug I'm
sorry I'm so
sorry I hate the top of death because
you always remember the people that you
care about that are gone so again it
really
hurts and that's so sorry apologize
don't apologize you're
human you guys can go while I get my
voice back together you need anything
from us no thank you so much I really
appreciate
it were you finished um yeah I mean I
feel like yeah I lost two partners and
that kind of I feel like watch ing being
with them as they died really made me
not first of all a there's things that
are worse than death uh B I don't have a
fear of going to hell anymore
um I feel like I've already been through
hell I just feel like
oh if all there is is Blackness after
this just darkness like yeah let's go
let's go like the big nap please yeah
bring on the big nap yeah relax I just
want to R
yes uh for me I guess it's very similar
why should I fear something that in its
simplest explanation it may just be
nothing it may just be no experience no
pain no suffering and I'm fine with
that I would say I don't personally fear
fear death because I believe I know
where I'm going but I'd be lying if I
didn't say it wasn't something that ate
me up inside to think of people that I
know and if they don't know Jesus and I
even pray like maybe on their deathbed
you know cuz I I think we have family
not everybody's Christian in my family
um not everybody's living what I believe
to be a Christian Life um so I think
about that and that is that is hard and
I know there's a lot of people's
perceptions of Christians is that we
want to send you to hell so
bad and that's not it so of course not
that's
all you all
right if you keep talking I'll probably
be over it
so yeah I actually agree with that as
well you know I used to fear death a lot
being in that type of Lifestyle um you
know I would carry a gun because I was
afraid of dying actually you know people
think that oh we want to hurt people no
actually was a defensive mechanism for
me but now that I'm similar to the
sister here like by faith I feel like I
know where I'm going and likewise I feel
bad about my friends so that's why um
you know some of the people in my gang
are are actually my family members my
brother my uncles but for me luckily I
kind of keep my faith in God and allow
God to save a person cuz like we're all
here right I can't change how you think
I can't change how you I can only you
know uh speak and then from my
experience and if you guys accept it you
accept it you know so yeah I'm I'm happy
with that well even if you don't want it
I'm going to be praying for y'all just
you know I'm definitely going to be
praying for you not just like just just
praying for you uh for your wellbeing
for for everything so I think everyone
here is fantastic and stuff like I
genuinely by the way would love to talk
to you about I want to hear like some of
your thoughts and stuff like that and
stuff but I would genuinely want to be
friends with everyone here like I feel
like I can hang out and so I know that
me and her are going to be super tight
so I think that you need to do standup I
I do stand up you do yes I told you say
didn't I say she might actually do it I
called it I want to say as a as a
Christian Pastor um I want to apologize
for
uh some of the things that you've
experienced in the church and um no
excuses I'm not going to say oh nobody's
perfect but um that shouldn't have
happened there was abuse and judgment
and uh that's not what Jesus stands for
thank you and I I do disagree that I I I
believe that you know that God is real
I'm going to go back to that but let me
just say you know what I'm not convinced
bro I I do wish the best for you and you
as well yes insan I like you're going to
get me again don't you I got a little
cuz like I didn't have like good father
figure so that was really
nice you're wonderful hope you know no I
I really appreciate that you all came
you know with your belief but not
prelati or forcing as other uh people do
I like and would love that this that can
spread out out in a way that everyone
can let everyone practice their way of
being a good human being and the things
that are private to be kept
private thank you for being open thank
you all of you guys thank you very much
we're all looking for something to fill
that void inside of us right some of us
it's Jesus some of us it's you know
really wild sex
um ain't nothing wrong with
that
can I give you a hug are so swe thanks
brother I appreciate you
hug meet up we have to go out we should
I got to give your info you're wonderful
you are you are amazing so nice to meet
you amazing you got a friend for life in
me man oh than you do too